the jurgen experience the country is not
about anything other than money
i mean we just abandon every value other
than
profit maximization and the bottom line
that's what people need to understand
about all this woke [ __ ] yes it's really
not about changing culture
yeah it's about money i mean that's
that's about power you know it's just
like it's funny there's a big um
article in new york times today about
inside an amazon warehouse
right and amazon was the first to say
black lives matter and put that
banner up on their page and everything
and look i support
a lot of goals of that movement but you
read through this article and you find
out first of all
the way they treat their largely black
and brown warehouse workers
i mean it's despicable they
intentionally make sure they cannot move
up the ladder
but that's part of their business policy
is if you're an hourly worker
you're not going to get promoted and
they try to force you out after three
years because they think you're getting
lazy
so this is the company that can on the
surface level say
black lives matter because they think
that's good for their profit
maximization and their brand and their
shareholder value
um at the same time what they're
actually doing in real life
wildly different than that so and they
specifically target black and brown
people well they target their warehouse
workers
who are so the warehouse workers are 50
some percent
black and brown management is 50 some is
overwhelmingly white and asian what is i
thought the whole thing about amazon
was that you could move up the lab nope
walmart who i'm also not a fan of
they actually promote from within so
most walmart managers
start out as hourly employees so at
least they have a track up and again
i'm not a fan of walmart okay amazon
intentionally and this is what the new
york times revealed they intentionally
have a system because bezos said he
believes that
these human beings are lazy and that
after
you know that they're going to do the
bare minimum saying this bezos is quoted
saying they're listening
i'll fight for jamie if you can fold
here yeah i think there's a difference
between lazy and having a shitty job
people need to understand that when
you're abused you're treated like a
robot and a cog day in and day out
you're fire like if you are a little bit
slow on your task you might get fired by
a freaking
app like that's how you dehumanize it
let's explain to people don't understand
how it works over there does anybody
want yeah i mean they work in the where
right so they have at phones that are on
there everything's tracking your
movements steps bathroom breaks as well
so
the warehouses are also very large so
let's say you technically have a
20-minute break it might take you 10
minutes to actually walk
to the break room and back so you
actually have what like a 2-minute break
while you're in there and the whole
thing around amazon and why everyone
should care
is because amazon under the pandemic
exploded their stock price went up from
i think
one thousand or so to a cup three
thousand bezos personally
his wealth increased by 70 billion
dollars
amazon is now the second largest
employer in the united states
and this is incredibly important because
as more amazon market adoption
happens they are basically going to
become the employer of choice whatever
your grocery store or whatever was
in your small town these are the rural
working class americans
this is their only job so when you have
one company
which has all of this overwhelming power
over
rural working americans and even
suburban americans because this is
amazon strategy dayton ohio is a good
example alec mcgillis he wrote a great
book
on amazon shout out to him talked about
how dayton was like this silicon valley
of america in the 1900s
you know manufacturing middle class jobs
now dayton's prized economic value
comes from the fact that it's one day's
drive from one third of the u.s
population
so it's a great place for cardboard so
everybody there
is all just involved in creating
cardboard and other amazon
infrastructure so the amazonification so
to speak or whatever
of america makes it so that if let's say
30 years ago you grew up in your town
you may have to go to walmart heb we're
here you know i grew up here in texas
kroger
as well mcdonald's something like that
now it's basically like mcdonald's dairy
queen and amazon and when amazon is the
prime market employer
they are the sole determiner of market
conditions increasingly so it's
walmart and amazon which are number two
and we're talking about
millions of people who are now working
at this company so
people are like why do you guys talk so
much about amazon because i can see the
trends this company's not going anywhere
look
props to them like they're i love amazon
like i order a lot of stuff on amazon
but increasingly becoming aware of the
price
of what it takes to do overnight
delivery to your house at 4 am in the
morning
or increasingly becoming aware of the
fact that they are basically
on this mission to drive price down as
much as possible
and squeeze as much out of their
workforce
that is worse trouble what was the
furniture thing that we just covered
yeah this is crazy well and did you see
their delivery drivers
have so are so like the the demands are
so intense they're having to pee in
bottles and [ __ ] and bags
right and they admit that they're [ __ ]
in bags literally yeah that's why i draw
the line i don't
really care if a guy has to pee in a
bottle but if a gal has to pee like a
dog bowl
right i'm like this seems yeah i mean
this happens
i would like to click the button that's
like i'll pay a little bit more if you
can promise me no driver had to [ __ ] in
a bag in order to get this to me
tomorrow we we kind of glossed over this
thing where you said that
yeah so i got the quote so here's here's
what the new york times says
amazon's founder jeff bezos did not want
hourly workers to stick around for long
viewing a large disgruntled workforce as
a threat
um this other executive recalled who
worked at amazon but then left
company data showed that most employers
became less eager over time he said and
mr
bezos believed people were inherently
lazy what he would say is that our
nature as humans is to expend as little
energy as possible to get what we want
or need
that was embedded throughout the
business from the ease of instant
ordering to the pervasive use of data to
get the most out of employees so
guaranteed wage increases stop after
three years
and amazon provided incentives for
low-skilled employees to leave
so every year they would offer
associates thousands of dollars to
resign they
made sure that any position they gave
people sort of the illusion
of promotions being available but then
there'd be one promotion available
for hundreds of people and they very
seldom
um higher or higher management from
within their own ranks it's like they
view us
it's totally class stratified is
basically the bottom line and of course
lower classes in america are
disproportionately black and broad it's
not like they're specifically targeting
black and brown people
but you have one class of people that
they see that as worthy of doing the
grunt work and [ __ ] in the bag
and one class of people that they think
is worthy of like actually having the
the more intellectual jobs and running
the place
it's you know it's a really abhorrent
way of viewing human beings
essentially and so this is part of the
kind of
again rot of america that i also think
is reflected with the john cena
thing etc it's like you're certainly
more of a capitalist than i am but
you can't have a country where the only
freaking value is money like that's
it's just it's just you you see the
sickness of
people who have all these addictions and
are last year was the worst
year on record for overdose debt you see
the suicide rate spike i mean
you see people who just feel like they
have no meaning and no purpose and no
grounding and no community
and all the life being sucked out of
these human beings in these communities
it's just disgusting catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience